breaking news out of the supreme court
politico is reporting a leak of the
supreme court's opinion in dobbs versus
jackson women's health this is the
decision that could potentially overrule
roe v wade and planned parenthood vkc
this is the decision that could
potentially obliterate the completely
fictional national right to an abortion
that was established in 1973 the leak
itself is shocking unprecedented you've
never seen this kind of a breach of
trust from the supreme court but from
the decision that we've got this is just
a 98-page draft of justice sam alito
writing the opinion of the court
according to this leak if the leak is
legit
the supreme court is voting to overrule
roe versus wade and planned parenthood v
casey the court is voting to overrule
national abortion
most important decision in my lifetime
if this is legit from the draft quote
row was egregiously wrong from the start
its reasoning was exceptionally weak and
the decision has had damaging
consequences and far from bringing about
a national settlement of the abortion
issue row and casey have inflamed debate
and deepened division we hold that row
and casey must be overruled the
constitution makes no reference to
abortion and no such right is implicitly
protected by any constitutional
provision including the one on which the
defenders of roe and casey now chiefly
rely the due process clause of the 14th
amendment that provision has been held
to guarantee some rights that are not
mentioned in the constitution
but any such right must be deeply rooted
in this nation's history and tradition
and implicit in the concept of ordered
liberty the right to abortion does not
fall within this category until the
latter part of the 20th century such a
right was entirely unknown in american
law
the constitution does not prohibit the
citizens of each state from regulating
or prohibiting abortion row and casey
arrogated that authority
we now overrule those decisions and
return that authority to the people and
their elected representatives
obviously if this is legit
obviously this is the right decision
it's right constitutionally it's right
legally it's right morally there are two
theories now on how this got leaked one
theory is that it was a liberal
a liberal
activist who is working for
us justice sonia sotomayor sotomayor is
the furthest left member of the court
and so a lot of the chatter is
surrounding her staff the second theory
is that this may have been a hack
this went to the politico national
security reporter so maybe it wasn't a
leak from the court maybe it was just
someone going in and finding it in the
court emails i for one suspect it was
the former i bet this was a leak this is
the sacrament for the left killing
babies on the altar of progress is
their highest sacrament we're not
talking about safe legal and rare we are
talking about
abortion on demand without apology
shouted from the rooftops people are
shocked at the leak they're shocked they
say that that you would have this kind
of breach of trust on the court i'm not
shocked at all of course they leaked the
opinion these people kill babies okay if
you're willing to kill a baby you're
probably willing to leak a document the
only purpose the only purpose to leaking
this right now
is to intimidate the conservative
members of the court into changing their
opinion and protecting the license to
kill babies all around the country the
secondary purpose will be to pressure
democrat legislators into making roe vs
wade the law of the land but the chief
goal here is to intimidate the
conservatives on the court do not let
them do it we knew there were going to
be shenanigans now more than ever now
not just in my lifetime probably in the
last 50 years of politics now more than
ever is the time
to hold strong if
this opinion is legit
if the court is voting to strike down
roe v wade and planned parenthood be
casey
then donald trump has already secured
his spot as one of the greatest and most
consequential presidents in the united
states
ever in american history
this takes us all the way back to
election 2016. the big debate over well
should we support trump well trump's got
some problems and he seems to have been
kind of liberal in the past but do well
but the judges but roe versus wade but
getting those conservatives on the court
well it's not worth it i don't think
he's going to really do it and the
judges won't hold firm if this opinion
is real
this resolves the question
this resolves the question because one
trump ended up being a very relatively
conservative president much more
conservative than anyone thought uh
trump did not turn out to be the crazy
maniac who was going to overthrow
democracy he didn't do any of that but
but more importantly
he will have been the guy
who got roe v wade overruled by getting
three judges onto the court
now what the libs want to do is leak
this so that one they can cause riots in
the streets two they can get death
threats to the conservatives on the
court that's what they're doing that's
what they're out for it's the only thing
that they could be out for
and as part of that pressure campaign
they'll be pressuring the liberals in
the house and in the senate to pass a
national law saying that that abortion
is a protected right now they don't have
enough votes for that right now
because you'd have to get over the
filibuster you need 60 votes in the
senate that doesn't exist you're not
going to get joe manchin to vote for
this i don't think you're going to get
kirsten cinema to vote for this so then
they'll have to get rid of the
filibuster all in order to to serve up
more innocent little baby sacrifices to
their their
idol moloch that's what it's all about
they just are trying to kill more babies
when you put it in those terms it's so
sick it's so sick but it's a mania and
it is their most deeply
cherished
right quote unquote in the country and
so they're going to try to do that and
they think that this will help them in
the midterms that's that's the long game
here they think that turning this
election into an election about abortion
is going to help them i think they're
wrong about that i don't think there's
any evidence that this is going to help
them i think infanticide plays not
nearly as well in peoria as they all
think that it will
i mentioned yesterday on the show i said
i'm not making any predictions here but
i'm a little worried about the dobbs
decision the reason i was worried is
because john roberts suggested that he
was not going to write the opinion of
the court and i said i'm not making any
any predictions here about how the case
is going to turn out but it seems like
some things are a little off here
it seems like something so
if this is the case that sam alito is
writing the opinion of the court
then we don't know who this very well
might be a 5 4 decision we just don't
know maybe roberts is going to side with
the liberals we're just we're not sure
the thing we know right now though is
this this draft was written in february
february 10th is what it stated
if this is the opinion it will be the
most important political development in
my lifetime really of the last 50 years
we're talking about 60 million babies
60 million we all use euphemisms when we
talk about abortion
and women's health care and reproductive
rights and then we all use these we're
talking about 60 million babies the
number is unfathomable how many people
in this country should be walking around
right now and are not because of this
decision in 1973
this is
absolutely earth-shattering stuff
and actually even beyond the question of
abortion this this leaked draft of the
the court opinion has achieved another
shocking goal which is all of a sudden
everyone's a biologist
all of a sudden you're seeing memes
again
no uterus no opinion
this is a war on women you're seeing all
these arguments from 10 years ago i
thought we didn't know what a woman was
katanji jackson on on this now will soon
be on the supreme court
said that she can't tell what a woman is
because she's not a biologist all of a
sudden everybody's a biologist sam alito
can tell you what a woman is and all the
people reading samulito can tell you
what a woman is
absolutely
earth-shattering stuff and i won't let
the libs get me down they're trying to
gum this up they're trying to pressure
the conservatives to switch
what the conservatives need to do right
now
just come out with the opinion
i don't know if it's in its final draft
this goes all the way back to february
so presumably it's in much better shape
come out with the opinion
if the opinion is substantially
different
from this draft
then we will know that the libs have
succeeded
at pressuring at threatening violence
that's really what this is about right
you you whip up all of the riots you're
gonna have a whole lot of mostly
peaceful demonstrations coming out with
molotov cocktails and rocks and all the
rest of it and it will make a mockery of
our system of government i never want to
hear about the the norms our norms are
sacred cherished democratic norms i
don't want to hear it from the left
anymore i never want to hear the stupid
phrase january 6th this is
so much more egregious an attack on our
democracy than january 6th ever was it's
not even comparable it's not even
comparable the leaking of this document
i never want it i don't want to see any
more crocodile tears from the libs if i
see them i'm just going to collect them
in my leftist tears tumbler
the opinion is phenomenal news the leak
is really
scary news especially for the judges who
are going to be threatened now so now is
the time stand firm guys you can do it
stand firm this is the moment this is
what we're all here for
glad you liked that clip now ding ding
ding ring that bell subscribe get
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you